what oil price should economists be
modeling into economic forecasts for
2015 and say the next one or two years
out from that I don't want to get very
specific with numbers but I will say
this that there's something fundamental
that's going on and we saw it sort of
very quietly a while back when Saudi
Arabia when was ordinarily would be
cutting back to gain arrest ability in
the market chose not to and prices began
to fall and continued to fall and the
markets continued weak in others largely
because the structure of the market has
changed the marginal producers of
gradually becoming the shale producers
the role of OPEC remember has always
been to rebalance supply and demand and
they had an extraordinarily successful
period over the years and decades in
doing that but the difference between
shell and the ordinarily OPEC type
Croods is that shale can be jock can be
altered in production very rapidly and
we're seeing that we will see this
shortly so that what is kakari is that
OPEC is no longer the marginal producer
and as far as I'm concerned at the
moment OPEC is not functioning and I'm
not all convinced that short of a major
change in the Saudis view of the future
but that's going to fundamentally change
so so and the implications of that are
or what precisely that we should expect
as a result oil to remain if not at
these levels fifty five dollars a barrel
for Brent or fifty six something in that
neighborhood I don't
the problem that we have is there are
certain types of things we can't do with
so little information that we have now
on this very new structure of the market
to pinpoint where Brent is going to sell
six months from now or a year from now
is actually going to us the reason I say
that we have not yet seen the structure
of the market as stabilized until we
begin to see that functioning with the
actual I would say curtailing of shale
crude and what we're obviously seeing a
significant cutback in investment now
and we're seeing significant cutbacks
and in drilling Lange look until we
basically get a catch of how this is all
manoeuvring I don't think we know where
the equilibrium price of oil is